DIVISION.
FIRST YEAR FOR THE COYOTES
MOVING TO THE CENTRAL DIVISION>
DEEP.
.
>> Brendan: ADRIAN KEMPE FOUR
GOALS IN THE LAST TWO GAMES.
BACK-TO-BACK TWO-GOAL GAMES FO
TIME.
DOUGHTY UP THE BOARDS FORRANS.
E NFL.
THE NUMBER ONE GOALTENDER FOR
THESE ARIZONA COYOTES.
MOSER SENT IT TO TH
HE SERVED IT BEHIND FOR KOPITAR.
KOPITAR TO THELCHENYUK INVOLVED.
CAME OFF
>> Darren: STICK ON PUCKGIVES I.
KEPT ALIVE.
MOORE TWISTING.
BYFIELD BUT STOLY
ROUSSEL CAME IN ON A LINE CHANGE
AND GOT IN THERE O.
THIS ONE KICKED ON.ONTROL AS  TI
TWO-ON-ONE.
HAYTON I ICES FOR THE ARIZONA
COYOTES.
>> Darren: COYOTESLTZ.
KELLER TO THE NET AND HE SCORES.
AND KELLER BEATS HIS MAN TO THE
NET RIGHT OF THE SEASON.
SCHMALTZ GETS THE HELPER AND THE
KINGS COME RIGHT BACK.T THAT FR
STRALMAN.
THE SHOT FROM THE POINT LOA COUE
OF WARM CLIMATE TEAMS HERE IN
LOS ANGELES.
A SHOT AND ATHERE AND SYNERGY.
MOORE WITH A NIC
SCORES..
>> Darren: LET'S GO TNT.
THEN KEMPE.
KOPITAR COMING AGA STICK
AND OVER THE GLASS FOR A BREAK .
DANAULT HAD IT WIDE OPEN.
GOY BRODEUR, ON THE CLOCK.
SCORE HASN'T CHANGED IN TH.
DOUGHTY TO KOPIT BREAKS THE TIE.
LEFT SIDE CHYCHRUN.
DROPPED TO